thanks again for
for having me uh today i'll share
some past work on uh designing for human
ai complementarity and then towards the
end of the talk share a little bit more
about
current ongoing work and emerging
directions
so ai systems are increasingly used to
support human work in deeply social
contexts such as classroom teaching
healthcare and social work
in these kinds of contexts ai can
automate routine parts of practitioners
work
while freeing up time for activities
they find more meaningful
and ai can also help practitioners make
more informed decisions
but these benefits do not come without
risks
so for example the use of ai risks
automating away human interactions that
people might not want
to lose in recent years we've seen for
example protests around the use of
ai-based learning software in schools
where the software has been viewed as
diminishing social interactions and the
role of the teacher
in the classroom
modern ai systems are also susceptible
to learning spurious patterns and
harmful biases from data
and they risk propagating these biases
at an unprecedented
scale and speed they lack many of the
common sense
or pro-social reasoning abilities that
humans may take for granted so they can
also fail in ways that a human would not
such as assigning high grades to
well-structured but gibberish student
essays
a long line of literature suggests that
in many domains
humans and ai systems have complementary
abilities and limitations
while the gap may narrow over time many
skills and occupations such as those
involving
forms of care work may fundamentally
defy
automation so to realize the benefits of
ai
and to mitigate its risks it's critical
that we design to take advantage of what
humans do best while also helping humans
overcome their own limitations
in my research i explore how we might
design systems that draw upon the
complementary strengths
and try to mitigate respective biases
of human and ai decision makers
the design of human ai partnerships has
been explored across a range of domains
but experiments evaluating their
performance have shown
mixed results several studies show that
when humans and ai systems work together
this can improve decision making
compared with either humans or ai
making decisions alone and so for
example successful partnerships
have been demonstrated between human
experts and ai systems in radiology
as well as other domains
but if not designed carefully human ai
collaborations can fail to improve
or even hurt decision making
so why do some human ai partnerships
succeed while others fail
oftentimes it's a simple lack of
human-centered design
for example a partnership might fail
when humans can't understand what the ai
system is telling them
though where that would be important for
it to succeed
other times it might be ineffective
pairing so for example many
null or negative results in this area
have come from
studies on crowdsourcing platforms like
amazon's mechanical turk
where crowds workers might be assigned
to assist an ai on tasks
that truly require expert level domain
knowledge which we wouldn't expect an
average crowd worker to have
so there's no reason to believe up front
that the humans and ai system
would have complementary strengths and
there are
various other uh reasons uh why human ai
partnerships might fail
um which i know is also an active area
of investigation
uh in my lab as well as based on the
conversations i've had today um
among various people at stanford
currently
so to design effective human ai
partnerships
we need to engage with the specific
contexts
where ai is used and to understand the
capabilities and needs
of the humans involved in those real
world contexts
in my group we take a participatory
approach throughout all stages of
building
human ai systems so we start by
developing collaborative research
partnerships with relevant stakeholders
we then work to engage these
stakeholders throughout the entire
design and development life cycle
for new technologies ranging from
initial need finding and ideation
to design decisions about the underlying
algorithms and
ranging to deployment of these systems
in the field
and when working with data-driven ai
systems today
this often requires the development of
new design and prototyping methods
for example to help stakeholders
understand and shape
algorithmic elements of new systems
design
using the outputs of these co-design
processes
we typically strive to conduct field
experiments
later in the process to understand the
dynamics and causal impacts of these
human ai systems
in the wild
so in this talk i'll share two major
themes of my research
um first i've explored how to co-design
more effective human ai partnerships
and second we've explored how to support
fairer decision making
within such partnerships and for the
sake of time
today i'll share just one prior project
under each of these broad themes
but i'm also excited to close this talk
by sharing some ongoing research in my
group
so i'll start with some work i've done
in k-12 education
where we developed an effective form of
human ai partnership
first for a bit of context in recent
years
there's been a push on k-12 teachers
to implement more personalized
classrooms
in which students work at their own pace
while the teacher's role
is transformed from that of a lecturer
at the front of the class
to more of an active facilitator of
students learning
to enable more personalized instruction
we're seeing
greater adoption of ai-based educational
software
so as an example intelligent tutoring
systems
provides students with step-by-step
guidance
through problem solving activities they
can
adapt instruction to individual students
based on
real-time models of students behavior
their knowledge
and even their effective states and
they've been demonstrated in several
meta reviews
to enhance student learning compared
with other forms of classroom
instruction
thinking back during my first year in
graduate school
i spent over 100 hours observing a wide
range of classrooms
using these ai tutors and in most of the
classrooms i
observe the teacher constantly moving
throughout the room and holding brief
one-on-one help sessions with their
students
so in practice ai tutors and human
teachers
really work together to help students
learn
but the role of the teacher in these ai
supported classrooms
has historically been understudied
and this partnership arguably isn't
working as well as it could
so for instance it's difficult for
teachers to monitor classes of
15 to 30 students who are all working at
their own pace
with each student potentially working on
entirely different material within the
software
many of the teachers i've worked with
have noted
feeling left out of the loop in their
own classrooms
during class sessions using these ai
tutors
but bringing human teachers back into
the loop
could have a great impact
uh so for example events regularly occur
uh in a typical k-12 classroom that a
human teacher might ultimately be best
suited to deal with
students might get frustrated find ways
to game the system
with getting through the material
without necessarily learning
other students may be missing key
prerequisite knowledge maybe from prior
grade levels
which lies entirely outside of the
instructional scope
of the software
so in this project we explored how
ai-based software and k-12 teachers
might work together more effectively
during a class session
allowing human teachers and ai to build
upon each other's complementary
strengths
rather than trying to automate what
human teachers
may already do best
to this end we worked closely with a
set of 36 core middle school math
teachers in the pittsburgh area
who were already using ai tutoring
software in their classrooms
often for many years in some cases for
over a decade
and i'll give you an overview of this
work ranging from our earliest
design explorations can you say what
software they're using are they using
like carnegie learning
software or what yeah absolutely so a
range of software
um carnegie learning uh assistance
um in some cases alex the majority of
the teachers
although only a slight majority were
learned using carnegie learning so
cognitive tutors
going from iterative co-design and
prototyping with teachers i'll also talk
about uh the classroom evaluation of a
new tool that emerged from all of these
efforts
um which was a set of mixed reality
smart glasses for teachers
called which at this point has been used
in
over 50 middle school classrooms
so we started this research by first
getting a sense of the
challenges that teachers currently face
in orchestrating these ai supported
classrooms
when we first started this work various
researchers in this area had begun
pointing out that the choices of
analytics
in existing teacher-facing tools often
appear to be influenced
more by existing technical feasibility
than by an analysis of teachers needs
so for example many existing like the
number of times that students have
clicked
on a certain button within the interface
but this sort of information was not
necessarily uh particularly helpful
found helpful by teachers so we wanted
to
in light of that begin this project with
a thorough defining face span
a range of design activities including
field observations and k-12 classrooms
directed storytelling to understand
teachers
past experiences using ai in the
classroom as well as
card sorting and speed dating studies
and so i won't go into
detail about all of these studies here
but more detail can be found
in these papers at the bottom of the
slide
just to provide one example in an early
study
we wanted to know if teachers could have
any information they wanted about their
students
in real time what would this be
and to do this without overly biasing
teachers towards ideas that they thought
were
already technologically possible we
asked teachers what superpowers they
would want
in these ai supported classrooms in
order to help them better do their jobs
among several other superpowers we found
that teachers consistently wanted to
be able to instantly see when students
were unproductively struggling and might
truly need a teacher's help
and also to see students thought
processes unfolding in real time
as they work through math problems for
instance
in a follow-up series of speed dating
studies with
teachers in which teachers are presented
with fictional scenarios presented in in
rapid succession we found that teachers
were particularly drawn to concepts that
would
allow them to see actionable information
about students learning
in real time while still keeping their
heads up and their eyes
focused on the classroom since so much
of the rich information that teachers
gain
is from actively looking at their
students so their faces
their body language so for example
this early concept sketch shows the ai
software essentially
raising a student's hand for them when
it detects that the student
currently seems to need help perhaps for
a
a long period of time even if they're
not asking for help
so to complement these sorts of
investigations of teachers own
perceived needs we also wanted to study
the interplay between
teacher and student behavior in actual
ai supported classrooms
to identify needs that teachers might
not themselves be consciously aware of
so for example in one study we collected
ai log data
and field observations from classrooms
by exploring these data sets through
replay visualizations and causal
modeling
uh we were able to identify some initial
opportunities
for these sorts of teacher analytics
tools to have a positive
impact in the classroom so as one
example
although most teachers believe that they
prioritize students
in their classes who need their help the
most
while using the software in reality they
mostly meet with students who
raise their hands most frequently not
the students who are silently struggling
so moving towards designing an actual
system
based on these insights we wanted to get
a more concrete sense
beyond these superpower ideas of
what real-time information would be most
helpful to k-12 teachers
while also getting a better sense of how
they might actually use this information
to inform decision making
and in this process we also decided to
explore this idea of
teacher smart glasses further so the use
of
wearable devices like smart glasses for
real-time teacher support
at this point was only just beginning to
be explored and
prior work had rarely made the link from
choices of analytics to teacher actions
that they might actually
inform in practice so to explore some of
these questions further
we conducted an iterative series of
design and prototyping studies
working with teachers in their own
classrooms at their schools
as an example from this phase of the
work in
low fidelity experience prototyping
sessions teachers would put on
plastic eyeglass frames and would look
at a scene of a classroom
on a computer screen when teachers put
the glasses
on we would wizard of oz analytics
uh overlaid on the classroom image and
these analytics were
based directly on the sorts of
superpowers that teachers had requested
previously
we also invited teachers to edit the
information that they saw through their
glasses
so whenever a teacher would generate an
idea for new information
we would press them to explain how they
envisioned actually using that
information
and we found that asking that that
question would often lead teachers to
refine their ideas
which were then incorporated into the
version shown to the next teacher
after encouraging feedback from these
prototyping sessions
we next moved to higher fidelity
experience prototyping
using the microsoft hololens
during each study session we placed
holograms throughout a teacher's
physical classroom
and we were able to modify these
holograms in near real time
based on a teacher's live design
feedback by
editing images that were synced with the
app while the teachers
viewed these through the hololens
teachers also have the opportunity to
experiment with decorating their
classrooms with different combinations
of information displays
while thinking aloud and providing
design feedback
so if you're interested in learning more
about this mixed reality prototyping
process
you can check out the medium blog linked
here
or these research articles which
describe it in more detail
so by this point in the process uh out
of a very large
initial design space we converged to a
compact set of
real-time indicators that appear to be
most useful to teachers
and these included what teachers
believed were key moments for them to
step in and intervene for example when
a student is misusing the software in
some way
or when a student is unlikely to learn
their current material by
working with the ai tutor alone
we also settled on two displays that
would pop up when a teacher clicks on an
individual student's
indicator so for example
if the ai tutor diagnoses that a student
is struggling
with particular skills the teacher's
classes would display both the skill
and some concrete examples of recent
errors that the student made
and these concrete examples were really
important to teachers
so teachers would often use them to
second guess the a tutor's diagnoses
and to try to infer underlying causes of
the student's difficulties
so we next began developing a fully
functional prototype
called lumilo in this case instead of
wizard of ozin the analytics as before
now analytics would be streamed live
from
ai tutors to the teachers glasses
and here you can see uh lulu in action
with
an off task student
in addition teachers could click on
individual students
to peek at the more detailed information
so before bringing this prototype into
actual k-12 classrooms many open design
questions remained
but to support co-design and prototyping
at higher fidelity
we needed to create a number of new
design and prototyping methods to
address challenges in working with
data-driven ai systems
so for example we wanted to involve
teachers not just in high-level design
decisions about
the kinds of information to be presented
but also in
in helping to shape the specific
algorithms that were used to
drive lumilo's analytics
so we developed a new prototyping method
called replay enactments
replay enactments embed participants in
immersive
simulations based on replays of actual
data from field contexts
in order to help make the consequences
of particular algorithm design decisions
more tangible to stakeholders even if
they know
very little about ai
during a session a human wizard makes
live changes
to algorithmic elements of a system's
design based on stakeholder feedback
for example the parameters of a machine
learned model
this allows stakeholders to experience
the consequences of their requested
changes
and then to rapidly iterate with the
wizard
so for instance in the lumalow project
teachers worked with the wizard to
experiment with different specifications
for
lumolo's learning analytics we invited
teachers into
a school computer lab and there were no
students present
but instead we simulated a class session
from historical data
so that if the teacher looked at the
computer screens it looked as if there
were students
working although ghost students in this
case
and teachers could then experience the
consequences of particular design
decisions they'd ask for
while wearing lumilo and moving
throughout the lab space
if you're interested in seeing some
actual clips from some of these sessions
you can find them at this link
so replay enactments is one response to
recent calls in the hci and design
communities
for new kinds of prototyping methods for
data-driven ai systems
by using authentic data and algorithms
replay enactments can help reveal
critical issues that conventional wizard
of oz studies
can't surface for example the interplay
between
human decision making and a prototype's
false positives
and negatives and by conducting these
sessions
in simulated classrooms first we gave
teachers a space to
iterate without risking harm to students
so at this point we we're ready to move
into actual
ensure that the version of lumilo we had
co-designed with teachers
was likely to have a positive impact
when we started this work there were no
principled approaches out there
for ensuring the educational
effectiveness of
teacher analytics tools like lumelo so
we developed
a data-driven design approach called
causal alignment analysis
or caa for short
applying caa in the iterative design of
lumolo
meant first making our hypotheses about
lumilow's mechanisms of action explicit
and then iteratively prototyping lumilo
with teachers and students
during classroom pilots we tracked what
teachers did
and how they allocated their time during
class sessions
with this data we used a causal modeling
approach to evaluate whether the tool
seemed to be having desirable effects
with respect to
our theory of change but also to
evaluate whether the theory of change
itself
seemed appropriate
so using caa we iteratively refined
lumelo
over four pilot studies and in the end
the resulting version of lulu actually
appeared to direct teachers attention
where it was most needed in the
classroom
these pilot studies in actual classrooms
also grew our understanding of
how this human ai partnership might play
out in the real world
so a major theme was that teachers did
indeed make decisions
based on complementary data sources they
had access to
in the moment they would combine what
they saw with their own eyes and ears
with what the ai system was telling them
about their students
and this often played out in interesting
ways
so in one particularly memorable case
lumilo alerted the teacher that a
particular seventh grader might be
off task in the software
but based on what the teacher knew about
this student
they thought that this was a bit strange
and out of character
so rather than taking the alert at face
value the teacher initiated a
conversation with the student
and asked how the student was feeling
that day
and the student ended up revealing that
their girlfriend had broken up with them
the weekend before
so this teacher in turn gave the student
permission to take the day off
from math if they wanted to
well this is an extreme example in some
ways
compared to many of the other
observations we had
it does illustrate one form of
complementarity on the ground
the ai diagnosed a student behavior and
alerted the teacher
but the teacher then made a rich
inference about the underlying cause of
the behavior
and responded with support and
flexibility that an
ai tutor could not provide
so piloting lubelo in 30 middle school
classrooms
provided an opportunity to collect many
other rich observations
including students perspectives on the
experience of having
as one student put it a cyborg teacher
at the end of each classroom pilot using
lumilo
we conducted whole class feedback
sessions
in general lumilo was very well received
by both teachers and students
but we also observed pretty strong
tensions between
teachers desires for augmentation versus
students desires
so unfortunately i don't have time to
dig into the student side of the story
um in this talk
which would take us into an entirely new
project
um but you can learn more in this paper
at the bottom
uh where we developed a co-design method
called participatory speed dating
to promote a form of iterative design
negotiation
among different groups of stakeholders
so using this method
students and teachers were able to
reflect on one another's perspectives
regarding issues such as privacy
and control agency in the classroom and
they iteratively generated new design
solutions
to resolve conflicting perspectives
so finally we conducted a field
experiment with lumilo
to evaluate its effects on student
learning
we wanted to investigate the hypothesis
that this form of teacher ai partnership
directing teachers attention to
situations that the ai tutor
might be poorly suited to handle would
enhance student learning
compared with business as usual in an ai
supported classroom
in which the teacher does not have
real-time analytics
and also compared with a weaker form of
classroom monitoring support where the
teacher can
see what's on students screens through
their glasses but without any
uh analytics
so we wanted to use this second stronger
control condition
because prior empirical findings suggest
that students
mere awareness that a teacher is
monitoring their activities
may have a significant effect on their
learning
and we wanted to tease apart the effect
of real-time analytics
over and above any such motivational or
novelty effects
from a practical perspective this is
also an interesting control because
it resembles the level of support that's
provided by
many existing classroom management
systems
with which several of the teachers we'd
work with were already
quite familiar
so to test these hypotheses we conducted
a three condition experiment
with 343 middle school students across
18 classrooms eight teachers and four
schools and school districts
students worked with lynette for this
study which is a tutor
for linear equation solving in algebra
and this is a cognitive tutor
much like the carnegie learning system
and all teachers uh in the study had
previous experience
using ai tutors in their classrooms
and had at least five years of
experience teaching math at a middle
school level
since the experimental treatment in this
case is classroom wide
we randomly assign classrooms to one of
three conditions stratifying within
teacher
the no glasses condition was business as
usual
for one of these ai supported classrooms
where teachers would circulate
throughout the room without any form of
support
or augmentation by contrast
in the glasses condition the teacher
wore a stripped down version
of the smart glasses which did not show
any analytics
however teachers could still click on
individual students
to see what was on the student's screen
at the moment
and finally in the glasses plus
analytics condition the teacher used the
full version of lumolo with all of its
analytics displays
the procedure was then the same for all
three conditions
students first took a pre-test
students then work with lynette for two
class sessions while the teacher
monitored the class and
helped their students and finally
students took a post test
in addition to students pre and post
test scores we tracked
individual student process data in the
ai tutoring software
and we also used lumilo to track the
teacher's physical activity in the
classroom
so i developed a logging library for
lumolo enabling it to double as a
powerful data collection device
to track teacher behavior during a class
session for example the indicators
um floating above each student's head
would essentially double as proximity
sensors
to track a teacher's physical position
in the classroom relative to each
student
moment by moment finally
we used hierarchical linear modeling to
analyze student learning outcomes
finding that three level models have the
best fit
so the results supported the hypothesis
that
this form of teacher ai partnership
enhances student learning
compared with business as usual for ai
supported
breaking this down a bit part of the
benefit of a teacher's use of lumilo was
due to their use of the glasses
even without any advanced analytics
however a teacher's use of real-time
analytics had a positive effect
on student learning above and beyond any
effects of the classroom monitoring
support
that was provided in the glasses
condition
to better understand the mechanisms by
which this effect
may have arisen uh i looked at how
teeter's allocation of time
across students of varying prior
knowledge
um was influenced by the experimental
condition
i found that compared with the two other
conditions
when teachers had access to real-time
analytics about their students
they tended to spend much more of their
time working with
students who had come in with lower
prior knowledge
in turn i found that providing teachers
with
real-time analytics serve to shrink
achievement gaps
within the classroom compared with
business as usual for
an ai supported classroom for students
in both the glasses
and no glasses conditions we saw the
rich get richer effects that are often
observed with classroom use of cognitive
tutors
students coming in with higher prior
ability tend to benefit more from
working with the tutoring software
however for students in the glasses plus
analytics condition
the post-test by pre-test curve was
flatter
than in the other two conditions meaning
that
when teachers had access to real-time
analytics about their students
lower pre-test students learned more
finally i looked at how a teacher's use
of lumilo
affected students behaviors and for this
purpose
i looked at the very same student
behaviors that lumelo
tracks interestingly some of the largest
effects of lumilo
on the frequency of these student
behaviors can be attributed to the
simpler classroom monitoring support
that was provided in the glasses
condition so a plausible explanation for
this
is that when students believe that their
teacher has magic eyeglasses that let
them see
everything they're doing in the software
the frequency of the very behaviors that
lumelo was designed to detect
goes down
so one key takeaway of this is that
future studies on teacher analytics
tools like lumilo
should try to tease apart the effects of
the analytics themselves
from other potential impacts of a
student knowing that
they're being monitored as we did here
in summary i found that when teachers
and ai
work together using lumilo students
learned significantly more than they
would
working with an ai tutoring system alone
presenting teachers with real-time
analytics about student learning
metacognition and behavior at a glance
served as a sort of equalizing force in
the classroom
helping to narrow the gap in learning
outcomes between students
who were coming in with higher versus
lower prior knowledge
and although there's been a lot of
interest in teacher analytics tools
this is actually the first experimental
study to demonstrate
that real-time teacher analytics can
enhance students learning outcomes
which is really exciting
so lumilo is an example of a successful
human ai partnership
achieved through co-design with
practitioners in a real-world context
next
i'll share how i've applied uh the start
of a similar research approach towards a
second theme in
my research supporting humans and ai
systems
in drawing upon each other's
complementary strengths to make fairer
decisions
i've talked a little bit about how ai
can help humans make fairer decisions
for example lumilo help teachers
distribute their time more equitably
across students
but ai systems can also exhibit
undesirable biases of their own
so for instance real-time analytics in a
teacher tool
might have greater accuracy for some
populations of students
while producing misleading outputs for
students from
minority groups or an automated essay
scoring system
might learn to grade certain students
poorly because of the particular dialect
they use
rather than necessarily the underlying
quality of their writing
so next i'll share some work i've done
towards
helping humans improve fairness and ai
systems
this was a collaboration with a group of
machine learning researchers at
microsoft research
investigating industry product teams
needs for support
in creating fairer machine learning
systems
by unfairness in machine learning i mean
very broadly
cases where systems favor certain
individuals or groups
over others in systemic undesirable ways
so we've already seen some examples in
education but there's been
many high profile cases across many
domains at this point
and these kinds of algorithmic horror
stories are making their way
into the news with increasing regularity
a range of academic research disciplines
have picked up on this
and there's been a huge surge of papers
on fairness and machine learning
we've also seen many high-level calls to
action in the field aimed at those
responsible for developing and
maintaining these systems
or for regulating their use at a policy
level
and beyond these calls to action a lot
of machine learning research has focused
on the development
of algorithmic methods to monitor
and mitigate undesirable biases and
machine learning systems
as this field matures we're starting to
see the creation of developer toolkits
where developers can input their data
and models and the toolkit will generate
a bias report
based on fairness metrics that exist in
the literature
so these toolkits take existing
algorithmic fairness methods from
machine learning and try to push them
into use in the real world
but if we want real-world adoption of
fairness research
it's crucial that this work is informed
by an understanding of
actual needs for support of the
practitioners who will ultimately use
them
despite widespread attention to biases
and unfairness and machine learning
practitioner-centered studies
historically have been very rare
so in this work we conducted the first
systematic investigation in the
literature
of industry product teams needs for
support in developing fairer machine
learning systems
we wanted to investigate what went wrong
in the kinds of disaster stories that i
mentioned earlier
and how we might better support
practitioners in avoiding these kinds of
incidents
a major challenge in this work was in
gaining product teams trust
we specifically sampled teams who had
received negative press coverage about
their ai products
so in some sense they had every reason
not to talk openly with us
practitioners were used to others
critiquing products from the outside
rather than engaging with product teams
to try to solve problems collaboratively
so shifting to a collaborative mindset
was key to developing trust in this
context
just as it was in my prior work with
k-12 teachers
we conducted one-on-one interviews with
members of 25 product teams
across 10 major technology companies and
our aim in these interviews was to
better understand teams current
practices around unfair machine learning
at critical decision points for each
major decision point
we asked participants to recall specific
challenges they'd faced
and to describe how they'd handled them
at the time and we also
probed participants needs for additional
support in such moments
finally we supplemented our interviews
with an anonymous survey of 267
participants
who work on ml based products in a range
of roles
including data scientists ux researchers
data labelers and product managers
among others
so our meta meta takeaway from this work
was that there
were indeed major disconnects between
the research literature
on fairness and machine learning and
industry teams actual needs for support
and this misalignment between research
and practice was much like the
disconnects that
i'd observed in my work with teachers
between the types of information
provided by existing learning analytics
systems
versus teachers actual information needs
so given limited time i'll uh summarize
just a few of the themes that emerge
from this work
product teams often reported struggling
to make use of existing quantitative
fairness metrics
in other words the problem was often not
that these teams lacked access to fair
machine learning research
but rather that fair machine learning
research addressed different problems
than the ones they were facing
as one example of this although most
existing fair ml methods
presume access to demographic data at an
individual level
several of the teams we spoke with are
only able to collect demographics at
coarser levels such as neighborhood or
organizational
level statistics and this is for legal
reasons in some cases
for example in the united states you
generally cannot collect individual
demographics of k-12 students
another of our most striking findings in
the study was on the role of data
so the fair machine learning literature
generally assumes that data sets are
pre-existing
and fixed the focus is then on designing
fair models or
algorithms to optimize quantitative
fairness criteria
in contrast industry practitioners often
have some control over their data sets
especially at larger companies and this
is the first place they're likely to
turn when
attempting to address fairness issues so
several interviewees voiced
needs for tools that can help actively
guide their data collection efforts
for example the quote shown here is from
a machine learning developer who works
on
automated essay scoring applications for
k-12 students
to collect their training data their
company gathers examples of student
essays that are graded by teachers
but they found that in the data their
team collects african american students
rarely receive high scores from teachers
and in turn
their models end up replicating these
biases in subtle ways
so the team wants to find cost-effective
ways to
collect more balanced representative
data sets in the first place
as a third major theme interviewees
often expressed anxieties about their
own blind spots as individuals and as
teams
so for example the fair machine learning
literature
will typically assume that the
subpopulations we want to be fair
towards
are known or even defined by law
in contrast many practitioners worried
that they have blind spots here
and expressed needs for support in
identifying which subpopulations to
consider in the first place
some teams reported uh having a practice
of getting together with a whiteboard
and trying to imagine everything that
could possibly go wrong with a
particular system
so they could make sure to monitor for
those issues in advance
but inevitably once a system is deployed
particularly when it's deployed globally
the public discovers issues that the
team failed to anticipate
so for these reasons participants noted
that it would be nice to somehow
pool knowledge of potential pitfalls
across teams with different cultural
backgrounds
who may have complementary knowledge as
well as complementary blind spots
and one way to facilitate this might be
to create mechanisms for greater sharing
of test sets across
organizational boundaries which encode
nuanced knowledge that
no single team is likely to have
some interviewees also shared stories
about their own cultural blind spots
as teams so for example we spoke with
one team that was working on a globally
deployed image captioning system
that's purports to recognize celebrities
from around the world
the team received many complaints from
non-us-based users
since the system seemed to work well for
us celebrities
while misidentifying or misgendering
celebrities
from their countries so the all-american
team
had great data on american celebrities
like fiance
but when it came to celebrities from
taiwan or
korea the team members had trouble
telling different celebrities apart
and as a result they often made errors
when curating the data sets
one promising direction for future
research in this space
may be to support teams in the ad hoc
recruitment
of diverse team external human experts
for particular tasks where in some cases
here
relevant expertise may simply mean being
immersed
in a particular cultural context at a
particular time
so while i was only able to summarize a
handful of findings from this work today
many more are covered in our kai paper
when we started this project
participatory approaches to work on
fairness and machine learning
were rare the practitioners we worked
with
expressed appreciation for having their
voices heard
rather than simply having researchers
and the media critique their products
from the outside working alongside
product teams
and really engaging with the particulars
of specific products
can raise interesting design and
technical challenges
and in turn this can productively guide
more basic research
and theoretical work in machine learning
building on our findings from this work
we developed a research agenda for
future collaborations between
hci and machine learning researchers
which
centers on supporting the humans
involved throughout the ai development
pipeline
and it's been really exciting to see
uptake of this agenda by others in the
field over the last few years
this research agenda has also directly
informed a lot of the ongoing work
in my group so on that note
before we open for discussion i thought
i'd kind of briefly share
some of the directions we're working on
currently
my group at cmu the koala lab focuses
broadly on
studying and designing new forms of
human ai collaboration
in particular a lot of our projects
focus on care-based
social and creative forms of work
we're interested in helping humans and
ai systems better assess
inform and potentially contest or
disagree with
each other's decisions and to do this
work
we're working across various real world
contexts where ai systems are already
being used to guide
really high stakes impactful positions
such as social work
education mental health care and
software design and development
we're particularly interested in
designing tools to empower workers in
contexts where
ai has the potential to help but which
fundamentally resists
full automation and these include many
care-based professions where human
empathy and relationship building are
central
but despite resistance to automation
care-based labor
remains chronically undervalued we can
see this with underpaid and overworked
social workers
school teachers in k-12 and caregivers
for children
the elderly and people with disabilities
one current project we're working on
under this theme focuses on
co-designing algorithmic systems and
platforms to empower
in-home caregivers which is currently
one of the fastest growing segments of
the american workforce
increasingly we're seeing companies
introducing new algorithmic systems to
transform what
in-home care work looks like but many of
these systems tend to be designed in
ways that
center the needs of clients and
employers while further disempowering
the caregivers themselves
so in this project we're working with
caregivers to co-design
new worker-centered prototypes for
example fair scheduling algorithms
interactive voice assistance and
community platforms that support
knowledge sharing and collective action
another set of projects we're working on
focuses on the design
and empirical evaluation of new tools to
help machine learning practitioners
assess and address unfairness in the
systems they develop
so following up on the research agenda
that i mentioned previously
for example in one ongoing project we're
designing interventions to address
problems rooted in
organizational and team behavior at
companies our aim is to work with
industry practitioners to
redesign existing fairness toolkits like
i mentioned earlier
so these toolkits are commonly tailored
for use by machine learning developers
and their designs provide little
opportunity for input or collaboration
with other team members
so we're exploring design opportunities
to instead promote
more collaborative work practices where
ux researchers social scientists
and others with relevant expertise for
thinking about fairness
have a seat at the table
in one more ongoing project
i'll mention and then i'll wrap up we're
creating and empirically evaluating
a new collective auditing platform so
our goal in this project is to empower
everyday users of algorithmic systems
in addition to crowd workers to surface
unfair or harmful algorithmic behaviors
as
early as possible whether to product
teams
or to advocacy groups or so forth
and this project aims to overcome
limitations that we've observed in our
prior work
with product teams existing practices
for user testing
or auditing their own systems
so that was just uh kind of a quick
overview of some directions we're
pursuing now
um you can check out our website for
more information and to learn more about
the many students and collaborators that
i have to thank for making any of this
work possible
also beyond today's discussion uh feel
free to reach out via
my email list here as well as my twitter
handle
so thank you
thank you ken excellent so
panelists you can go ahead and unmute
yourselves and ask questions if you'd
like
we also have some questions from folks
who are
attendees uh panelists does anyone want
to jump in first
okay then i will um so we have a um
a student uh asking she mentioned
you mentioned that convincing these
machine learning research practitioners
to engage and collaborate with you was
really difficult so how did you build
that rapport and how did you build that
trust
yeah that's a great question um i think
i guess kind of thinking back um coming
from a lot of work that i've been doing
in the education space i was a little
taken aback by although in retrospect
i'm not sure why this was that
surprising um and how long it took
to get started on that research how long
it took to build those partnerships
compared to
how long it would typically take to
build relationships with
school admins teachers students parents
and so forth
um it was an iterative
process of learning the wrong ways to do
it
over time we essentially
tried to understand a practitioner's
concerns
tried to understand concerns of legal
departments through some conversations
there as well
and uh started including more language
in our emails to
really try to assure uh our emails and
our communications where we'd have quick
follow-up calls
um that our goal here is not to write a
call-out paper we are not going to
work with you and then write a chi paper
or some other conference paper
in which we're talking about all of the
problems in uh your particular product
we are trying to actually understand
your processes
to improve those processes that was one
important piece
the second was definitely um
uh setting up clear processes for review
making sure that the practitioners
and anyone else at their company who
might need to would be able to review
any direct quotes that we include
in papers and to review the ways in
which we were
de-identifying particular companies or
particular teams within companies
thanks and wondering how do the
anti-anti-bias and fairness designs gain
traction without violating
equal protection or if you have thoughts
on that kind of trade-off
yeah so are you thinking about kind of
broadly in in this space just fairness
interventions in general
i think that's the question but it's not
my question so i can't
exactly clarify i i think maybe
maybe the right thing is to say there's
just discussions around equal
protections
and uh fairness and so on so
i guess asking for your thoughts having
been really in this space for a while
yeah absolutely yeah that that is a real
tension in some domains
definitely more than others um
and uh in projects we're kind of getting
off the ground now i mentioned one of
the ongoing projects
is working within a team so looking at
uh
interactions between say ux researchers
and developers and product managers
on another project that's just getting
off the ground now
um we're looking at a broader ecosystem
including internal
uh legal experts like the ones that we
were negotiating with to get
access to practitioners for co-design
work in the first place
um to try to understand uh the processes
by which
uh these trade-offs are negotiated and
how they navigate
um in in many cases competing objectives
in the fairness space
when working on actual products whether
the
analytics you used in um lumilo were
limited to quantifiable situations as as
he put it like taking tests
and was wondering how representative
those kinds of situations are of
learning more broadly
sort of like what can and can't this
help with
yeah that's a great question i mean i i
would say by definition
kind of the analytics are limited to
quantifiable uh
situations uh
or actually maybe i'm misinterpreting
the question a bit so
so i i i if i understand quickly you
might be thinking about kind of asking
about whether
um the constructs being measured the
sorts of things that that were
that we're getting at are limited to a
fairly
small scope i think that's absolutely
true
and um i i do i will give a shout out to
um there is a lot of work in the area of
learning analytics
ai and education that tries to expand
that scope um but when it comes to for
example
um affect detection uh
it tends to be the case that our our
best models are
pretty bad compared to human performance
at least if the human has
um has certain stimuli available to them
that they would have in a classroom
environment
and is attending to a student in the
moment which are strong assumptions
um so i i yeah i think the short answer
i'm not sure if i'm completely answering
the question
is absolutely it tends to be the case
that
um and there's there's a broader
discussion within the
ai ethics for education space about the
ways in which the constructs that are
most easily measurable
might limit um the sorts of things that
we and maybe more importantly teachers
on the ground
end up attending to given that that's
what makes its way into tools
um and thinking about the ethical
implications
of that potential narrowing so that's
something that i think about a lot
not just in education honestly but in
every domain that i work in
including social work any projects in
healthcare this is
really a broader problem okay
i'll jump in with a question um in
lumelo it seemed like you did the
co-design
with the teachers and not so much with
the students
i you mentioned that one effect
of um your study with the students
was that when the teacher had the
glasses on the students knew
um you know they were being watched um
i'm i'm curious about other feedback
um that you got from the students and
and if you can anticipate
um if you could do co-design with the
students
um might there be ways where they could
articulate
how i can be supported in this
you know um learning system that
sometimes works for me and sometimes i
have difficulty with
yeah that's that's a great question i'm
gonna actually
bring us back to this slide so we um
i'm actually going to say a regret i i
regret not
uh working with this is actually a
different way of working than
um than i typically do now in projects
for the most part
typically now i think if i were doing
this project
i would try to involve students more at
an earlier stage
one of the reasons we did this the time
is that a major gap in the literature is
that
so much work had been focusing on ai for
students and so we were interested in
filling this gap and hearing teacher
perspectives
um the slide i'm showing here is a piece
that i a piece of the story that i
didn't really get to talk about today
which is the co-design with students
um and again i feel like in retrospect
we brought this in a little bit too late
but we learned a lot through this
process and it was
uh actually one of my favorite parts of
this project from a
participatory design methods perspective
in which we were iteratively
kind of facilitating these iterative
negotiations between teachers and
students
having them generate new designs
critique each other's designs
talk about what's insensitive about a
design created by teachers but which
teachers feel
are really enhancing their abilities um
and so
in this paper shown at the bottom we
talk about a lot of the
concerns that students had the reasons
why
teachers felt strongly about having some
of those designs
ultimately we were for the most part
able to get to a place
where um we would alleviate
any major concern students had for
example venturing into the territory of
affect detection
um really really went into the
creepiness territory for students
whereas
other analytics that we had students
would actually agree oh it seems helpful
for my teacher to know that
um so we were exploring some of those uh
tensions
but by the end of this process uh we got
to a place where
students were happy with the design
and uh teachers even though they might
be disappointed that some features they
wanted were not in there
we're still we're still overall happy
with the design
so this was really a process of
navigating trade-offs
and that i should mention um not all of
these changes the majority of these
changes
were not reflected in the version that
we tried in the classroom study
and that's that's where some of my
regrets come in of have we started this
process earlier
more of these uh design changes would
have uh
we would have been reflecting student
and teacher needs a bit a bit more
in the experimental study that i covered
excellent i'm noting we're at time so
why don't we end it here thank you so
much for sharing this with us
uh everyone please silently clap with
your videos on or off
thank you for having me yes